[Music]  understand what's going on around you  you are in a state of war and you have  precious  little time to save yourself  [Music]  is a slow process which we call active  measures  [Music]  the first stage being demoralization  it takes from 15 to 20 years to  demoralize the nation  the next stage is destabilization  what matters is essentials economy  foreign relations defense systems  the next stage is crisis  with a violent change of power structure  and economy period of normalization  this is what will happen in the united  states if you allow all these schmucks  to put  a big broader government in washington  dc  they will promise lots of things never  mind whether the promises are fulfilled  or not  [Applause]  the time bomb is ticking but every  second  the disaster is coming closer and closer  the danger is real